you buy all the products you put them on
your face and then your skin gets worse rude
today we're busting five skincare
myths that are ruining your skin
and i swear we are not just going to
talk about wearing sunscreen every day
myth number one high concentrations are
better it makes sense that we feel this
way if five percent of something is good
then ten percent must be twice as good
but there's diminishing returns when it comes to
skin care it's like eating burgers one burger is
good two burgers is maybe better but then
ten burgers oh you start to feel like trash
or cake ingredients one teaspoon of vanilla
extract is nice two is better the whole bottle
maybe a bit much and if the whole cake
is made of vanilla extract it's trash
same with actives it's about hitting that sweet
spot if you don't have enough of something it
has no effect if you have too much of something
then it's too much you're in side effect territory
for skincare this is usually irritation or
stripping your skin barrier you know you've
done this if your normal products or maybe even
water start to sting when they get on your face
your skin might go red and feel
tight it might be weirdly shiny
you might also get bumpy which is sort
of the opposite of what you are going for
irritating your skin also leads to
inflammation and inflammation is
also not good there's this term
inflammaging that some brands
have been trying to make catch on for a
while now it hasn't really but the gist is
inflammation can speed up some of those changes
that happen in your skin over time not good
inflammation is also one of the four factors that
contributes to acne so stick with a concentration
that makes your skin happy don't try to go
higher just for the sake of going higher
and if it says to start on a low percentage start
at a low percentage don't try to cut corners
myth number two you should exfoliate flaky
skin this also seems like it should make
sense your skin wants to come off
so you help it off with exfoliants
but sometimes the reason skin is flaking off is
because your skin's natural shedding processes are
messed up and adding exfoliants will probably
mess it up more if your flaky skin is red
or irritated then adding an irritating
exfoliant into the mix is not going to help
so if that's your situation leave it
alone let it chill maybe slather on a
nice soothing cream like la roche-posay's
cicaplast baume or even just vaseline
lack of hydration can also sometimes mess up
your skin's desquamation desquamation is the
fancy name for your skin's natural exfoliation
process okay sometimes you do need to get rid
of dead skin flakes really quickly like if
you're about to put on foundation in that
case you can exfoliate it off super gently
with a damp towel or a gentle peeling gel
just to break off the dead skin at the
surface but apart from that leave it alone
myth number three using every
active ingredient every day
this happens a lot you have a day routine and a
night routine but you want to use 10 products so
you use 3 in the morning 7 at night now some
people enjoy having a nice long routine but
you probably don't need one
and sometimes it is too much
quite a lot of actives are fine being used
less regularly than once a day you can use
them once or twice a week for example there
are studies on tretinoin which is a vitamin
a product where they're used once every
three days vitamin c is believed to have
a depot effect in other words it stays in your
skin and stays working for more than 24 hours
there's also exfoliation it's usually recommended
that you only exfoliate once maybe twice a week
so you don't need to use every product every day
the best approach is to learn to listen to your
skin and give it the products it needs and not
mess it up more when it's already a bit messed up
i talk more about getting to know your skin in my
ebook the lab muffin guide to basic skincare but
basically you want to keep track of what you're
putting on your skin and how your skin responds
keeping a skincare diary is a good way taking
photos is also good you should also change one
thing at a time so you can see how your skin
actually responds and remember if you use too
much you can get irritation you can mess up your
skin barrier and get that textured uncomfortable
type feeling and that stinging that inflammation
can also lead to accelerated aging and acne
i personally use a three night cycle on night
one i'll use a retinoid on night two i'll use
a chemical exfoliant and then on night 3 it's
the rest night where i use gentler things like
niacinamide and vitamin c for me vitamin c
is quite gentle but for some people it's not
so again listening to your skin is super important
myth number four cleanser doesn't matter
because you're washing it off your skin
sorting out my cleanser and my cleansing routine
was one of the things that made the biggest
changes to my skin there's actually quite a
lot of scientific research on cleansers like
how to make them more gentle how to make
sure they're not contributing to acne
but there's still a lot of cleansers on
the market that don't follow the rules
for example cleansers should have a low ph
and contain some hydrating ingredients to stop
from stripping your skin make sure you look
up reviews from people with similar skin to
you before you buy a cleanser i actually
did a couple of videos on cleansing myths
a while ago and i think i forgot this myth i
have oily skin so when i was younger i used
a pretty harsh cleanser i used it twice a day
and it dried out my skin but then what happened
was it felt like my skin was really tight and hard
and the oil just sat on top and after i cleansed
in the morning and then put on makeup the oil
came back really fast and messed up my makeup
once i got better at skin care i switched to
a gentle cleanser once a day and my skin has
been so much happier makeup lasts for much
longer it doesn't sort of flood back with
oil as quickly also if you're wearing a mask a
lot you might end up with skin issues from that
wearing a mask means you're trapping moisture
against your skin and that extra moisture changes
the microbes on your skin and also makes
your barrier a bit more permeable there's
also that extra friction and there's just a lot
of irritation and inflammation going on there
taking off your mask when it's safe and
cleansing underneath is a really good idea
if you're out you can use wipes or micellar
water also check for how you're cleansing as well
so check your water temperature and
also what cleansing tools you're using
myth 5 sunscreens are all awful i kind of
lied but i see a lot of people trying to
make the wrong sunscreen work i don't mean
in terms of chemical sunscreen or physical
sunscreen or what spf but just what works
for you and so many sunscreens are just
annoying they might roll off your skin they might
break you out they might just feel really terrible
i blame men there are a lot of white
dudes in the skincare industry who
don't use skincare they use shampoo on their
face and they're making decisions about what
products we get and so this crappy
sunscreen situation means a lot of us
aren't using enough sunscreen or we
might just skip sunscreen altogether
but there are more women and men
who use skincare or they're just
good at listening to what their customers
actually want they're more considerate
are getting into decision making roles and
so there are a lot of better sunscreens
hitting the market so don't feel like you
just have to put up with bad sunscreens
not all sunscreens are awful a lot of them
feel really nice on your skin and a lot of
fear-mongering about sunscreen ingredients and
rules for what sunscreen you're meant to use
aren't really legitimate anyway
it's more about finding a sunscreen that
you enjoy so you're happy to wear it every
day and you can apply a decent amount so
about a quarter teaspoon for your face
like and subscribe to promise to
yourself that you'll do better
and let me know the worst myth
you believed in the comments